So let's talk about Rogers for a minute.
He was a devout fundamentalist Protestant.
And I think that's important to know because a lot of his thinking has a very
strong Protestant flavor.
I mean,
the reason I concentrate on such things and the philosophical background,
if these thinkers,
because you have to understand the axioms,
the safer that you're dealing with dirt,
you actually don't understand them at all.
And when you're assessing the axiomatic presuppositions of the paper,
you're usually outside the thinkers thought in some sense,
right?
Because you're looking at axioms,
but you don't get it unless you,
unless you know the accident.
And so Carl Rogers thought was deeply grounded in his Protestantism,
but it's,
his father in particular was a scientific farmer and applied the scientific
method on the farm that he grew up in.
And so Rogers had a devout fundamentalist background of the sort that was more
typical in the thirties and the forties but he also had us powerful,
uh,
understanding of the scientific method and practical observations of its
utility.
So
he,
his first academic training was at the Union theological seminary seminary.
In the mission of,
of that seminary was to evangelize the world in their generation.
If I remember correctly,
was when he was on a boat to China to serve as a missionary that he first
started to question the absolute reality of his,
of his Protestant beliefs.
It isn't that he abandoned particularly,
it's that he incorporated them into a approach to psychotherapy that fulfilled
all the preconditions for this.
There's a,
there's this striving towards a kind of interpersonal perfection that goes along
with Protestantism.
There's an idea that the most important realization of the most fundamental
reality is to be had in direct and honest communication between two people
and
two or more people.
That's a place where you might say,
if you're thinking about it symbolically,
that the living word emerges and Roger's thinking is deeply,
deeply rooted in that kind of conception.
And it's,
it's partly that he believed that if you could integrate yourself properly,
if you could put yourself together in some sense at every level of analysis,
then you'd be able to exist,
communicate in a way that was,
there's a Ph Eddie,
and for to this that was optimally beneficial to you,
but also optimally beneficial to other people at the same time.
And a lot of that would emerge in your interactions with each other in
communication.